- We're entering an era
in which our enemies
can make it look like
anyone is saying anything
at any point in time.
Even if they would never say those things.
So, for instance, they could
have me say things like,
I don't know, "Killmonger was right,"
or "Ben Carson is in the sunken place,"
or, how about this, simply,
"President Trump is a total
and complete dipshit."
Now, you see, I would
never say these things.
At least not in a public address.
But, someone else would.
Someone like Jordan Peel.
This is a dangerous time.
Moving forward, we need
to be more vigilant
with what we trust from the internet.
It's a time when we need to
rely on trusted news sources.
May sound basic, but how we move forward,
age of information is
gonna be the difference
between whether we survive
or whether we become
some kind of fucked up dystopia.
Thank you, and stay woke bitches.